Rene is in Charlotte North Carolina
hi Rene how are you hi I'm good are you
better than I deserve what's up okay I'm
gonna try to make this quick okay so I
got me a glass engine I'm trying
pregnant and I had $200,000 right with
it
so currently we pay $800 in credit card
payments I mean we was trying to figure
out that's one of our biggest expense
excluding rent
so shunted out is we should do a debt
consolidation because the interest rate
of 25% and also wanted to share one of
our cars but the cars worth 10k we all
about 21 k sure what you get $11,000
upside down in a car be wrong general
negative equity into that deal when you
traded it we bought a new in 2016 what
might come and it's worth only 10 value
and we went to like an infinity card
we're looking at wholesale prices not
retail so that car if you sold it on
Craigslist is worth more than that you
need like a private sale on Kelly Blue
Book it's worth more than 10 grand the
car does not lose half its value that
fast okay I hope okay so two hundred
thousand dollars in that how much of
that is student loans 110 and they're
currently on forbearance right now right
and what's your household income 145
thousand maybe I'll do for a living I'm
the accountant he works in IP good okay
how long you guys been a school and how
much a credit card debt is altogether 41
k okay and so that's 150 the other 50
cars so 44k car loan 41 k car credit
cards 17 K personal loans
the husband's NK in student loans okay
so we talked about one car that was
$24,000 so you have another one that's
20,000 what's it worth my car we didn't
think about feeling like what's it worth
I haven't even looked at the values it's
the 2016 Sonata so you went crazy in
2016 didn't you yeah both of them are
new at that time yeah that's that's a
fourth of your debt so you're wanting to
debt to consolidate the credit cards yes
it's 800 a month we pay minimum payment
okay
it doesn't hurt anything but it doesn't
solve your problem okay okay interest
rate on $40,000 out of 200,000 is not
your problem if we save you 10% an
interest rate that only is $4,000 $4,000
tons of it 200,000 other problem yeah
selling these cars and getting you a
couple of beaters and rolling up your
sleeves with your hundred and forty five
thousand our income doing anything you
can to get your income up and you don't
need to see the inside of a restaurant
again unless you're working there and no
vacations and scorched earth beans and
rice rice and beans have you cut up your
credit cards yet I have it because I'm
pregnant so I thought I may need it for
medical expenses you're not gonna get
out of debt okay you're gonna struggle
and go bankrupt if you don't stop this
see as soon as you start thinking I
might have a need you know what you did
you ran straight back to the credit
cards see that's a bigger discussion
that's a much more important part of
this discussion than your interest rate
on your debt consolidation you cannot
consolidate your way out of debt you
have to stop borrowing money kiddo
period forever okay you've made a mess
you have borrowed money until you can't
breathe you guys are borrow money like
you're in Congress so if you're ready to
stop and you want to change your family
tree for this baby I'll help you
it's called Financial Peace University
and I'll pay for it but you guys need to
go to that class and learn how to
this stuff and then you need to actually
do it you need to get out the scissors
and cut up the credit cards you need it
to every dollar budget out and really
tighten down here and say we have made a
mess and we are going to change we are
not buying anything ever again the rest
of our lives on credit you are two
hundred thousand dollars in debt you're
on the verge of bankruptcy you have got
to stop it
I'll help you I'll walk with you you
hold on I'll have Kelly pickup we'll get
you signed up for financial peace but
you go to those classes and learn how to
do this stuff and if you want some more
help you call me back I'll always tell
you the truth because I care about you I
want you to win